nada sous la silla the Council of today
agreed that European Union ratifies the
Paris agreement as soon as possible we
will ask the European Parliament for its
consent in Strasburg next week at the
plenary meeting of the european
parliament the decision of today
increases the probability that the first
conference of parties to the Paris
agreement will take part in Marrakesh in
November I'm ready in person together
with mr. can yet a deposit the
ratification instruments of European
Union and we are inviting all Member
States who have already ratified the
agreement on the national level to join
us Valley our partners are coming on
ball faster than anyone would have
imagined and Europe must show we can
deliver to that is why today we have to
take a giant leap forward towards
ratifying Paris and ultimately bring it
closer to enter into force and what
reputation was on the line because
remember that they said that Europe is
too complicated to agree quickly they
say we had too many obstacles they say
we were all talk and they even started
to question whether our Hardware in it
today clearly show that we mean business
today's agreement shows unity and
solidarity as members testicle European
approach just as we did in Paris and
this is what Europe is all about in
difficult times we get our act together
and we make the difference I now count
on the European Parliament to conclude
the process next week so far 61
countries covering almost forty-eight
percent of global emissions have
ratified agreement we have already
passed the keys r escrow for the
required number of countries and are
close to the second trigger 20 into
force so we need to be ready to join the
libyan as soon as possible